something remarkable happened in 2015 no
not that not that either definitely not
it's something I've been waiting a long
time for first Windows 10 made Windows
really great again
then something else happened Windows
laptops became great too you can now buy
one that you don't want to punch in the
trackpad or rip out its battery so I
present to you the best Windows laptops
you can buy right now my topic is Dells
13-inch Dell XPS 13 new updates to it
make it the best all-around Windows
laptop I've ever used ever it's
incredibly thin bezel makes it smaller
than most of the others but choose it
for its great trackpad and battery life
the newest 1080p model lasted 10 and a
half hours in my tests
hey macbook air you realize you look
like an old sock compared to this thing
right if you're looking for more of a
laptop tablet hybrid in this range the
HP spectre x360 is a good choice its
screen back flips and it gets seven
hours of battery life but what about
Microsoft's first ever laptop yes the
surface book is a good choice for power
users with money to burn but the Dell
XPS 15 is a better value the magnesium
surface book wins for the best feeling
windows machine plus it has a beautiful
screen a great keyboard and trackpad and
nine and a half hours of battery life
but at $1500 you're really paying for
it's a detachable screen that you'll
rarely use get a Dell XPS 15 if you want
more power and a bigger screen for a
lower price I have one basic Windows
laptop buying rule do not buy anything
under $600 and the assist sin book ux305
C is the best value I found it has a
1080p screen a very thin and light
design good enough performance for most
and 256 gigabytes of storage if you want
something under $400 the best Windows
laptop you can buy is a Chromebook
really the windows laptops I tested in
that category
we're pretty
pretty bad the keyboard on the $200
Lenovo s12 flexes more than Arnold
Schwarzenegger and it often stutters
when you're just trying to scroll down a
web page if you want a cheap laptop
that's good for fast web surfing and
email just go with the $250 toshiba
chromebook 2 now before you rush to the
comment section i did not forget about
the tablets with keyboards but i only
think you should buy one of these if you
plan to pull off the keyboard and use it
as a tablet to take notes watch videos
or surf the web I prefer the surface pro
4 to the other options from Dell and HP
because of that it's lighter than them
and includes a stylus but it's still no
iPad in terms of battery life or apps
hey I didn't say every Windows machine
was great there's always 2016